they broke through my front door they
blew off the garage door and they um
used a humby to uh plow down my back
fence that's Vicky Baker in 2020 a
fugitive barricaded himself inside her
house in Texas a SWAT team smashed every
window and destroyed the home nearly
everything was ruined and her daughter's
dog went deaf and blind then things got
worse her insurance wouldn't pay why
because many policies don't cover damage
caused by the government but when Baker
asked the city to compensate her
officials said the government had
immunity she's not the first in 2015 a
fugitive in Colorado barricaded himself
inside Leo Lex home a SWAT team did so
much damage that his $580,000 house had
to be demolished the city gave him only
$5,000 so how is this legal some courts
of rule that victims aren't entitled to
compensation when the government takes
action under police powers in 2020 the
Supreme Court declined to hear Lex's
case so for the foreseeable future there
will be innocent people left holding the
bag when cops destroy their property